[Musique]
bonjour mais quel dommage sens Politique
n'existe que depuis une dizaine de
semaines imaginées le chant du possible
si nous avions commencé cette émission
un peu plus tôt disons au 16e siècle
Jean tambazin qui prépare avec moi le
rendez-vous ce serait par exemple
démener pour qu'on ait Henri IV en
studio elle aurait convaincu le
communicant du roi Séguéla le Hardy de
l'intérêt d'une invitation sur France
Culture Henry serait venu en carrosse
officielle on aurait prévenu la sécurité
de la Maison de la Radio porte a pour
qu'elle remonte le pont-levis après son
arrivée car c'est une personnalité quand
même et qui n'a pas que des amis au fil
des minutes monsieur 4 ce serait détendu
oui c'est ça il aurait fendu l'armure sa
naissance à Pau sa passion tout au long
de sa carrière pour l'Europe il se
sentait aussi bien de France que de
Navarre favorable à l'ouverture des
frontières avec l'Espagne évidemment
puissant jamais oublier le Béarn il
monte à Paris à mesure que son destin
devient national l'entendre nous
expliquer comment il fait le siège de
Vendôme en 1589 et en devient duc
protestant encore il se convertit au
catholicisme prenant part à ce qu'on
appelle alors la conjuration des mal
contents un groupe de nobles catholique
et en même temps de nobles protestants
mécontents de la politique du
gouvernement Henri IV on l'aurait aussi
interrogé sur le sens de ses choix
structurels pour l'avenir du pays réputé
qu'il fut pour ses plans visionnaires et
comme nous sommes des gens délicats sur
France Culture je me serais abstenu
d'évoquer devant lui son assassinat rue
de la ferronnerie dans le premier
arrondissement de Paris tandis qu'il se
rendait avec son carrosse non blindé au
Palais du Louvre voilà bon faut pas
regretter parce qu'en fin de compte
Henri IV il n'a pas non plus le monopole
du destin Béarnais il ne l'a pas
regardez notre invité du jour dans sens
politique lui aussi il est né presque à
Pau 16 km un vol d'oiseau lui aussi
européen engagé le président même depuis
18 ans le Parti démocrate européen lui
aussi rejoint Paris et ses palais de
pouvoir lui aussi est réputé protestant
protestants contre Jacques Chirac contre
Nicolas Sarkozy contre François Hollande
il tente donc lui aussi plusieurs fois
logiquement propre conjuration du mal
content en se présentant la
présidentielle de 2002-2007 et 2012 pour
rassembler Jean de droite et en même
temps de gauche puis lui aussi ce film
ou un protestant il proteste moins en
2017 se convertissant au macronisme et
prenant d'assaut lui aussi Vendôme
précisément la place Vendôme pour y
devenir garde des sceaux et désormais
comme Henri IV lui aussi est connu pour
son sens de la prospective c'est même
l'une de ses activités puisque le voilà
depuis deux ans au commissaire au Plan
mais voyez comme on apprend des erreurs
de ces aînés je parierai que notre
invité Béarn et du jour ne passe jamais
lui par le quartier des Halles
lorsqu'ils seront au Palais de l'Élysée
François Bayrou bonjour bonjour soyez le
bienvenu dans sens politique au
commissaire aux plans ce plan qui a
navigué comme il a pu au fil de l'eau
parfois à contre-courant depuis sa
création en 46 par le général de Gaulle
on a commencé par l'appeler le
Commissariat général au Plan ou Duplan
chargé de proposer à titre indicatif des
plans quinquennaux et ainsi définir
planification économique du pays à la
sortie de la guerre votre prédécesseur
d'alors François Bayrou s'appelait Jean
Monnet et lui-même expliquait qu'il
s'agissait d'une fonction indéfinissable
alors est-ce que vous voulez bien 76 ans
plus tard François Bayrou relevait le
défi et nous donner le sens de cette
fonction du moins tel que vous l'occuper
depuis 27 mois
alors comme vous le rappelez juste titre
beaucoup de choses ont changé
et
le plan aussi en tout cas l'idée qu'on
se fait du plan l'idée du plan après la
guerre c'était un peu un plan à la
soviétique c'est-à-dire un état tout
puissant qui était chargé de
reconstruire la France avec l'aide des
États-Unis parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que c'est le plan Marshall
c'est-à-dire ces milliards de dollars
apportés par les États-Unis pas à fond
perdu
parce que quand vous donniez de l'argent
aux agriculteurs français pour acheter
des machines agricoles et que les seuls
fournisseurs de machines agricoles
étaient les États-Unis vous ne perdiez
pas tout
loin de là mais enfin bon
c'était l'idée que un pouvoir central
pouvait définir l'avenir du pays ça
reconstruction et ses états
et puis on s'est aperçu évidemment que
chaque fois qu'on centralisait il y
avait des erreurs et puis la mode
profondément changé et on est arrivé au
fil du temps à l'idée que il fallait pas
planifier que la vie que
les affaires que les investissements
privés
[Musique]
définiraient mieux l'avenir qu'une
vision plus
centralisée à l'époque Jean Monnet
devait établir des plans quinquennaux
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle des notes
oui parce que c'est des notes
stratégiques c'est ça le c'est ça le but
problème par problème alors évidemment
ça n'a plus du tout le la portée que ça
avait à l'époque mais cependant j'ai
toujours été persuadé et j'ai fait tout
ce que j'ai pu pour convaincre le
Président de la République que on devait
reconstruire quelque chose de cet ordre
toujours été persuadé que à avoir trop
le nez sur le guidon comme on dit pour
les cyclistes ou dans une autre manière
de s'exprimer à ne voir que l'arbre qui
cache la forêt l'arbre de l'immédiat
l'arbre de l'urgence
on se trompait et on s'est trompé à de
nombreuses reprises en raison de cette
courte vue en France je vais prendre un
exemple simple
peut-être je publierai un jour un livre
que j'ai déjà écrit sur ce sujet
l'établissement du numerus clausus en
médecine
le fait qu'on a décidé que il fallait
limiter contingenter le nombre de
médecins en France nous en payons le
prix aujourd'hui et le prix le plus cher
un grand pays médical comme la France
réputée dans le monde entier et qui se
trouve
tout d'un coup face à une pénurie de
médecins incapable de fournir des
soignants à la propre société française
c'est une erreur
majuscule et c'est une erreur qui est
due à l'absence de planification donc là
c'est un constat quelle prévision quelle
préconisations alors évidemment on ne
peut plus décider à la place de la
société française parce que la France
est un pays ouvert mais il y a des
choses il y a des sujets stratégiques
qu'on doit prendre
et nous l'avons fait de la manière la
plus j'allais dire la plus honnête
possible en donnant sur chacun de ces
sujets
une stratégie où on proposant une
stratégie lisible par tout le monde ça
n'est pas des tableaux Excel multipliés
des statistiques à perte de vue c'est un
constat et une vision stratégique pour
chacune des sujets je vais en prendre
quelques-uns on va en choisir un ou deux
vous allez l'électricité la démographie
lequel on choisit alors on en prend
l'électricité c'est très simple je crois
que que la note stratégique que nous
avons publiée sur l'électricité à jouer
un grand rôle dans le changement de
perspective qui a été celui de
l'exécutif en France
jusqu'à cette note le nucléaire c'était
banni
tout le monde disait qu'on allait vers
la suppression du nucléaire
et puis nous avons conduit une analyse
qui est assez simple et que je vais
refaire devant vous en quelques phrases
si le but c'est le
la confrontation entre énergie et climat
les engagements que nous avons pris à
juste titre c'est de baisser la quantité
de gaz à effet de serre que nous
envoyons dans l'atmosphère et notamment
du CO2
s'il faut baisser le CO2 alors il faut
exclure l'électricité produite avec du
gaz du pétrole ou du charbon
donc il faut aller vers du renouvelable
or il se trouve qu'en raison de la
situation géographique de la France en
particulier
renouvelable que ce soit
hydroélectricité que ce soit
éolien que ce soit photovoltaïque
se renouvelable là en tout cas pour
éolien photovoltaïque il a une
caractéristique c'est qu'il est
intermittent est-ce que c'est pas tout
le temps soleil il n'y a pas tout le
temps du vent et donc
s'il est intermittent il faut un
complément ce complément on l'appelle
pour des raisons que vous comprendrez
aisément le pilotable la production
d'électricité pilotable quand il n'y a
pas d'électricité produite par le vent
ou le soleil on injecte de l'électricité
et il faut une autre source la seule
source
qui ne qui n'émettent pas de gaz à effet
de serre disponible en dehors de
l'hydroélectricité la seule source c'est
le nucléaire et ça a changé la vision au
lieu d'opposer nucléaire et renouvelable
on a compris et je crois que la note du
plan a joué à un très grand rôle on a
compris que pilotable c'était le
complément nécessaire du renouvelable et
donc ça a changé la vision et ça a
permis de reprendre
tard après 15 ans ou 20 ans de
d'ignorance
d'ignorance du sujet ça a permis de
reprendre tard un programme
électronucléaire qui nous permettra avec
la crise énergétique que nous vivons un
jour d'être plus autonome votre rôle en
2022 comme en 46 du reste et consultatif
je le rappelle est-ce que c'est pas par
hypothèse assez frustrant pour quelqu'un
qui comme vous François Bayrou a été
quatre fois ministre et trois fois
candidat à la présidentielle non parce
qu'il faut de tout pour faire un monde
n'est-ce pas le une de nos forces
c'est que nous ne sommes pas partis
prenantes des combats souvent de clan
qu'il y a autour de la décision
politique je plaide pour l'impartialité
et ça c'est nouveau vous n'êtes pas
rattaché au gouvernement alors que vos
prédécesseurs depuis 46 l'était oui j'ai
beaucoup insisté sur ce sujet je suis
pas sûr que ça m'est rendu populaire
partout mais j'ai beaucoup insisté mais
vous en faites cette liberté pour être
rattaché directement au président de la
République parce que je considère que la
fonction dans nos institutions qui est
celle du long terme c'est la fonction
présidentielle et puis ça permet d'être
plus libre vis-à-vis des décisions
gouvernementales le gouvernement les
ministres sont toujours pris dans
un entrelat de pression
de il est plus plus intéressant pour moi
d'être un peu en retrait de ces
pressions là et donc je transmets
évidemment de notre stratégie mais je ne
les soumets qu'au président de la
République François epsamen le maire de
Dijon socialiste Macron compatible
l'ancien ministre du Travail réponse
aussi dans l'hebdomadaire Le Point
apparaître cette semaine quand on lui
demande pourquoi il n'a pas voulu entre
le gouvernement parce que je ne suis pas
fait pour être dans un gouvernement
aujourd'hui et puis les ministres c'est
plus que c'était ce sont plutôt des
chargés de mission est-ce que le prix de
la liberté François Bayrou pour un
acteur de la chose politique au sens le
plus noble qui soit c'est pas en fin de
compte de voir rester à l'extérieur du
pouvoir exécutif
on sait pas le temps est long
j'ai en effet comme vous dites postuler
à la fonction présidentielle et au moins
une fois en approchant d'assez près
le succès
2007 un peu plus de 18% et donc
bon et puis il y a des moments comme ça
un peu d'éloignement et puis
d'engagement dans l'action et je n'ai
jamais écarté l'engagement dans l'action
je pense que au contraire
c'est c'est ce qui donne sa dignité à
l'action politique mais comme par
ailleurs j'ai une fonction exécutive
locale dans la ville la région le pays
qui est le mien ça fait une vie assez
équilibrée le dernier commissaire au
Plan avant vous fut le regretté Alain
etchegoyenne philosophe choisi en 2003
par Jean-Pierre Raffarin il a tenté de
rénover l'institution et je me souviens
de la violence dont il témoignait et
qu'il décrivait dans un livre au titre
glaçant votre devoir est de vous taire
cette phrase titre goyenne la tribuait
au Premier ministre Dominique de
Villepin vous le commissaire au Plan
votre devoir est de vous taire
finalement Dominique de Villepin a
carrément supprimé la fonction en 2006
Emmanuel Macron la recrée en 2020 pour
vous la confier est-ce que vous êtes
certain François Bayrou d'être à l'abri
de ce genre de rappel à l'ordre
absolument certain
absolument certain pour beaucoup de
raisons c'est que comme vous l'avez
rappelé je me suis entouré de
précautions la première de ces
précautions c'est que je ne rends compte
qu'au président de la République et pas
au gouvernement parce que cet
affrontement entre Alain tcheguyen que
j'aimais beaucoup et Dominique de
Villepin cette affrontement là
il s'est déjà produit et Jean Monnet
raconte tout le temps dans ses Mémoires
le conflit qu'il y avait avec le
gouvernement les gouvernements les
ministres n'aiment pas que quelqu'un
interfère avec la décision exécutive
j'aime pas que que quelqu'un
pose les pieds sur le pré carré qu'il
considère être le leur je crois qu'ils
se trompe je pense que on apprend
beaucoup quand d'autres viennent
précisément sur le champ qui est le
vôtre pour apporter des idées ou un
regard critique ou ce que ce que je ne
fais pas donc
oui je suis sûr que que je ne je ne suis
pas exposé à ce risque j'ajoute que j'ai
pris une autre précaution j'ai décidé
d'exercer cette fonction bénévolement
intégralement bénévolement
ce qui me donne une certaine liberté
vous vous êtes par ailleurs donné la
mission presque donc qui je tienne de
vous bagarrer non pas contre des moulins
à vent mais contre des structures de
l'État qui revient peut-être même qui
considère les citoyens comme une gêne
dans la gestion du pays ce sont vos mots
là encore François Bayrou qu'est ce qui
fait actuellement vous conduit à cette
analyse et en bon commissaire au Plan au
commissaire au Plan qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez pour que le citoyen devienne
ou redevienne aminiment un acteur voire
un partenaire des structures de l'État
c'est un des combats de ma vie
vous avez rappelé le
milieu social d'où je viens et même le
milieu géographique d'où je viens c'est
à dire loin des cercles de pouvoir
parisien et je me suis toujours tenu
soigneusement à l'écart des
comment je peux dire des clubs des amis
cales des réseaux qui à Paris
structurent le pouvoir
j'ai toujours refusé d'y participer
pourquoi parce que je ne me sens pas
appartenir au Cercle on dirait en
anglais des in des gens qui sont dans le
pouvoir qui sont bien dans le pouvoir
qui dit le premier de cordé on pourrait
dire la France d'en haut et moi je me
sens plutôt des outs même si je connais
un peu le cercle des donc j'ai toujours
refusé par exemple j'ai été élu il y a
30 ans
très jeune au siècle
j'y suis allé une fois parce que les
gens qui m'avaient été lu sont
un club parisien
ou ou tous les pouvoirs se rencontrent
j'y suis allé une fois et j'ai dit à
celui qui avait engagé j'ai dit écoute
je suis venu une fois mais je viendrai
plus parce que je ne veux pas appartenir
au cercle privilégié
peut-être c'est une espèce d'orgueil de
ma part mais je tiens à être à
l'extérieur pour avoir la liberté du
regard
France Culture science politique
Arnaud Bousquet
dans cette émission François Bayrou nous
nous appuyons à trois reprises chaque
semaine sur des archives sonores pour
illustrer comprendre le sens de
l'engagement et de l'action politique de
nos invités je vous propose de commencer
puis ça peut être un lien d'une certaine
façon à ce qu'on vient d'évoquer
sur le club et la centralisation du
pouvoir par l'extrait que vous avez
choisi de partager avec nous sur France
Culture nous allons l'écouter ensuite
vous nous direz pourquoi vous souhaitiez
nous faire découvrir ou redécouvrir
cette archive dans le sens politique
François Bayrou on vous laisse d'abord
nous la présenter
c'est le général de Gaulle c'est le 30
mai 1968
c'est un moment
dramatique de l'histoire du pays parce
qu'il a failli quitter le pouvoir
il s'est même enfui il est parti à
Baden-Baden la veille la veille et il
revient en hélicoptère
et il décide de parler à la radio et
voilà ce qu'il dit française français
étant le détenteur de la légitimité
nationale et républicaine
j'ai envisagé depuis 24 heures toutes
les éventualités sans exception qui me
permettrait de la maintenir
j'ai pris mes résolutions
dans les circonstances présentes je ne
me retirerai pas
j'ai un mandat du peuple je le remplirai
je ne changerai pas le premier ministre
dont la valeur la solidité la capacité
mérite l'hommage de tous
Je dissout aujourd'hui
l'Assemblée nationale
Charles de Gaulle alors le premier
ministre évoqué à l'instant c'est
Georges Pompidou le coup de poker est
gagnant puisque c'est un raz-de-marais
pour les candidats gaullistes dans les
législatives qui suivent cette
dissolution il va quand même changer de
Premier ministre Couve de Murville entre
un Matignon et Pompidou en sort et va se
préparer à la succession de Gaulle qui
aura finalement lieu un an plus tard
quel est le sens de votre choix
d'archives alors soit je vous raconte
à peine 17 ans je viens de
fêter mon anniversaire je suis en
terminale
je viens d'être élu représentant des
lycéens de mon lycée c'est un souvenir
délicieux pour moi
représentant au Comité d'action lycéens
j'ignorais cordialement ce qui était les
comités d'action lycée vous étiez élus
mais mais j'étais très content d'être
élu
et et
c'était une ambiance révolutionnaire que
d'ailleurs les enseignants entretenaient
auprès de nous parce qu'il devait
imaginer que ainsi ils allaient pouvoir
mettre une partie de leur empreinte sur
la suite des choses et c'était et faire
descent ébullition on savait pas où on
allait
et j'ai écouté cet extrait avec mon père
donc je ne savais pas qu'il allait
mourir un peu de temps après
et ma mère
sur un petit transistor noir et jaune
sur le rebord de la fenêtre de la
cuisine il y avait du soleil 30 mai
sur la cour qui comme la cour des fermes
béarnaises et pavées de galets
il y avait des animaux
et il a commencé à parler et j'ai
découvert
quelque chose qui ne m'a plus jamais
quitté
quel était le poids de l'autorité c'est
à dire
quelqu'un qui jusqu'à une minute avant
était remis en question gravement par
tous les mouvements d'opinion
et il suffisait qu'il parle à la radio
il avait choisi la radio pas la
télévision pour renouer avec le De
Gaulle de 40 de Londres de juin 40 et de
Londres
et à la minute où il a fini de parler je
crois que la locution a duré 4 minutes
et quelques à la minute où il a fini de
parler c'était fini le le
sens physique des choses que le jeune
garçon que j'étais qui découvrait tout
ça
avec tous les enthousiasmes et tout et
tout et tout la langue de cette
adolescence à peine fini
a compris que c'était instantanément
fini et je n'ai jamais oublié
ce qu’une parole d'hommes est capable de
faire pour changer les choses devant un
événement historique
et pour moi
ce cette idée que au fond les hommes
sont capables de modeler l'histoire ne
s'est jamais effacée
dissolution il s'agissait de ça François
Bayrou
vous avez servi je crois que vous
resterez avec ce record pour un long
moment vous avez servi dans des
gouvernements sous 4 présidents de la
République différents vous êtes chargé
de mission au ministère de l'Agriculture
dès 74 et l'élection de Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing ministre de l'éducation
nationale sous François Mitterrand et
Jacques Chirac est plus récemment
quelques semaines ministre de la Justice
à l'entrée d'Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée
donc vous avez personnellement fait les
frais d'une dissolution celle de 97 par
Jacques Chirac vous allez un an plus
tard prendre la présidence de l'UDF vous
êtes à ce moment-là
conseiller vous étiez secrétaire
national non je vais appeler ça
Président je suis devenu président de du
centre
du CDS de l'époque qui s'est transformé
après y compris en UDF et j'ai pris
cette présidence en 94 et alors le sens
du positionnement d'un centriste à ce
moment-là François Bayrou ça veut dire
quoi oh ça veut dire deux choses qui
sont pour moi capitales première chose
il n'est pas vrai que la vie la vie
d'une société et la vie des familles ou
des personnes se divisent en deux
parties gauche et droite cette
bipolarisation est une manière de
de tromper les électeurs et de tromper
la vie de la nation
ça c'est la première chose et donc le
centre c'est le choix de refuser le
simplisme de la bipolarisation il y a
une deuxième chose c'est que le centre
garantit le plus réalisme si on refuse
la bipolarisation alors on entre dans un
autre univers qui est le plus réalisme
et on a droit à des opinions ou à avoir
le Cali de scope des opinions en France
il y a aujourd'hui je dirais il y a il y
a six grands courants d'opinion alors
certains se divisent entre eux mais il y
a six grands courants d'opinion
l'extrême gauche
partis socialiste les vers le centre
a l'air disons la droite de gouvernement
et l'extrême droite si grands courants
d'opinion on a droit aussi
et puis être d'autres viendront parce
qu'ils apporteront un regard différent
sur les choses vous allez vous allez
François Bayrou vous affranchir de
l'étiquette de centre droit au fil des
ans c'est absolument de l'UDF à l'époque
si vous êtes obligé de mettre un
adjectif et que le nom ne compte plus
donc en 2007 l'UDF est morte vive le
modèle le contenu a aussi beaucoup
évolué puisqu'il n'y a plus cette
étiquette de centre droit en quoi votre
centrisme celui du MoDem celui de votre
triple candidature à l'Élysée 2002 2007
2012 est-il différent du macronisme de
en d'autres termes quelles circonstances
ont permis Emmanuel Macron de réussir
dès la première tentative où vous avez
échoué voilà c'est on peut être
précurseur et puis après d'autres
viennent et puis on peut continuer à se
battre ou à partager le combat c'est la
même idée le elle n'a pas été exprimée
de la même manière et surtout peut-être
les temps étaient mûrs et la
personnalité même du président de la
République a rendu possible
ce succès que on avait effleuré disant
avant
mais sur le fond je vous fais une
confidence
j'ai très souvent parlé avec le
président de la République
je n'ai jamais eu de divergence
stratégiques avec lui et je n'ai jamais
eu de différence d'analyse avec son
regard sur la société française on en a
pas toujours tiré les mêmes conclusions
on peut avoir des nuances mais je dirais
que sur le fond
celui des présidents de la République
que j'ai vu qui est le plus proche de
cette aspiration c'est lui il est même
si j'ose dire un peu plus proche que
Giscard ne l'était ce que Giscard il
venait de la droite et même d'assez à
droite dans le parcours personnel qui
était le sien Algérie française ou en
tout cas l'attachement de l'Algérie
française et donc
Emmanuel Macron est plus et plus
stabiliser au centre vous dites 10 ans
avant donc 10 ans avant Emmanuel Macron
c'est 2007 on prépare les élections
municipales les premiers mois
d'existence du modèle et localement au
cas par cas vous donnez vie à ce qu'on
peut appeler désormais le et en même
temps en faisant partie de majorité de
gauche dès 2008 dans des grandes villes
comme à Dijon avec François epsamen
ailleurs dans des grandes villes
majorité à droite comme à Bordeaux
ce sont les électeurs ou c'est la classe
politique qui n'était pas prêt à cette
époque là pour transformer cet essai sur
des scrutins nationaux l'histoire à son
rythme et le rythme de notre histoire
collective de l'histoire de notre
société
était pas encore prêt à ça
c'est
c'est l'inconvénient d'être précurseur
d'être en avant Edgar Faure
qui avait sa personnalité à écrit des
mémoires et le premier tome de ses
mémoires s'intitule avoir toujours
raison c'est un grand homme et avoir
raison en avant
c'est pas un avantage c'est pas un
avantage pour exercer le pouvoir après
vous avez des satisfactions c'est à dire
que quelques années ou quelques
décennies après vos copains disent
viennent vous voir ils disent tu avais
bien raison voilà j'aurais naturellement
comme tout le monde préféré que
cette cette
justesse d'analyse entraîne les foules
pour qu'on puisse aussi exercer le
pouvoir directement parmi les différents
sens presque physiologiques des
centristes l'UDF hier le modem depuis
2007 il y a le sens européen
indissociable de votre engagement
partisan du reste les personnalités de
l'UDF devenant recyclage réceptique ont
quitté le navire et je voulais donc
consacrer la deuxième archive de
l'émission François Bayrou à la question
européenne extrait en lien avec votre
parcours personnel et votre engagement
voici une personnalité politique parmi
les plus populaires aujourd'hui 5 ans
après sa disparition des livres des
documentaires même un film il y a
quelques semaines
1979 ce sont les premières élections
européennes au suffrage universel direct
nous sommes le 4 mai 79 moins d'une
semaine avant le scrutin Antenne 2
organise un débat François Mitterrand
pour le PS Georges Marchais pour le
parti communiste Jacques Chirac pour le
RPR et voici Simone Veil qui vient juste
de quitter le gouvernement de Raymond
Barre pour conduire la liste
UDF je m'étonne un peu de ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Chirac l'Europe miracle est une
fille historique et je me demande si ce
n'est pas ce qu'il aurait dit il y a 25
ans exactement dans la même condition
par rapport au projet de traité de Rome
et cette Europe n'a pas été une fin
historique personne ne croit
actuellement que l'Europe résoudra tout
mais en même temps dans les gens de bon
sens les gens sérieuses savent qu'un
certain nombre de problèmes et c'est
déjà le cas actuellement ne peuvent être
réglés qu'au niveau de l'Europe les
problèmes de protection sociale nous le
savons tous on ne peut pas aggraver la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
si les autres entreprises européennes
n'ont pas les mêmes charges et on
pourrait donner comme ça quantité
d'exemples qui montrent bien que les
Européens sont intéressés à ce qu'il y
ait des solutions au niveau européenne
c'est le cas de l'environnement c'est à
l'énergie il faut absolument avoir un
plan européen en matière d'énergie c'est
le cas de certaines entreprises
industrielles on sait déjà ce que
l'Airbus a pu produire et les exemples
pourraient être multiples six jours plus
tard la liste UDF qu'elle emmène
remporte en France les élections
européennes et Simone Veil va devenir la
première présidente de ce Parlement
européen élu au suffrage universel
direct François Bayrou votre réaction à
se plaidoyer de Simone Veil pour
l'Europe en direct à la télévision et
peut-être aussi vos souvenirs à ce
moment précis vous avez 28 ans et déjà
engagé politiquement et plus seulement
au lycée
si comme je ressens là que tout est
juste dans ces affirmations
il n'y a pas un seul des problèmes
cruciaux qui se posent dans les sociétés
contemporaines et spécialement
aujourd'hui ou nos pays sont pris dans
le retour de la guerre de la guerre
physique sur le continent européen le
retour de la guerre
commerciale le retour de
de la question de des grandes des
grandes influences sur sur le choix des
pays de dimension moyenne par le nombre
il y a pas un seul des problèmes qui
puisse se régler si nous n'avons pas si
nous ne continuons pas dans le sens de
cette création absolument unique unique
qui est
l'union européenne volontaire forcée par
personne elle n'est pas le fruit d'une
victoire militaire elle n'est pas le
fruit de nasservissement ou d'une
soumission elle est la libre volonté des
peuples qui décident ensemble de se
rapprocher et de s'unir pour faire face
aux grandes tempêtes du temps
ça fait pas plaisir
mais ils étaient fascinés par Nicolas
Sarkozy et par les perspectives que
Nicolas Sarkozy leur ouvrait
le
problème de ce centre
a très longtemps été son tropisme pour
aller d'un côté ou de l'autre et
spécialement du côté du pouvoir
alors c'est pas agréable mais comme
toute ma vie atteste du fait que c'était
un engagement
fondamental pour moi à titre de citoyens
ce qui est peu importe ou de père de
famille
mais pour ce courant politique là
dont nous avons fini par prouver que oui
il était
légitime à exercer le pouvoir en France
donc j'ai oublié effacer tout ça
France Culture sens politique Arnaud
Bousquet
dernière archive sonore François Bayrou
bah c'est vous un morceau d'interview
dont je ne donnerai aucun élément de
contexte même pas la date vous ne savez
pas pour le moment quelle archives nous
avons choisi aujourd'hui dans Science
politique je vous propose de la
découvrir sur France Culture et vous
allez sûrement à l'écoute la resituer
facilement François Bayrou on vous
laissera donc nous dire dans quelles
circonstances vous vous êtes exprimé et
le sens évidemment de votre intervention
si Madame Le Pen n'a pas ses signatures
ça pose une question à la démocratie
française et je propose que les grands
courants démocratiques du pays en parle
entre eux pour percer
au pluralisme d'exister une seule
présidentielle San Marine Le Pen c'est
inimaginable en tout cas c'est c'est un
trouble donc je pense que il est
impossible qu'une formation politique
seule comme la mienne disent écoutez on
va faire ce qu'il faut parce que ça
ferait manœuvre je ne le ferai pas en
revanche en parler avec les autres
responsables politiques pour que le
pluralisme est droit de cité en France
je suis prêt à le faire
sont prêts ce dont je ne suis pas
certain on a reconnu l'accent de
Jean-Michel Apathie c'était sur RTL
est-ce que vous retrouvez la date ou en
tout cas la période
c'est la dernière élection
présidentielle non c'est l'élection
présidentielle suivante ce qui prouve
que vous avez de la
que je ne change pas souvent d'avis
c'était encore la précédente 2012 ah oui
ce qui prouve que je ne change pas
d'avis je pense que
y compris les courants politiques que
j'ai combattu toute ma vie
sans aucune exception
ont droit de citer c'est ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure à votre micro
je pense que il est légitime que la
démocratie
respecte et cultive le pluralisme c'est
d'ailleurs désormais inscrit dans la
Constitution
et nous avons joué un rôle important
pour que en tout cas certains de mes
amis ont un rôle important pour que ce
soit inscrit dans la Constitution
mais concrètement on est en 2012
qu'est-ce qui a changé dix ans plus tard
parce que Marine Le Pen affirme encore
que les 500 signatures sont difficiles à
obtenir et vous vous proposez votre
parrainage elles ont été très difficiles
à obtenir la failli c'est celle des
candidats qui a eu le plus de mal à
obtenir les signatures comment on sort
quel sort on sort de ça et que qu'est-ce
que ça aurait eu comme signification une
élection présidentielle dont un
déproteagoniste majeur aurait été exclus
est-ce que les Français s'y seraient
reconnus
elle a été au deuxième tour deux
élections de suite
et pour moi
vraiment
et l'ayant ayant combattu toute ma vie
ces idées ou ses arrière-pensées
je soutiens néanmoins qu'il est
nécessaire que c'est courant politique
soient représentés je ne veux pas d'une
démocratie qui soit confisquée par
y compris par ce que je respecte que
j'aime bien
la démocratie c'est fait pour que tous
les courants politiques puissent se
faire entendre et après c'est le combat
qui commence et ce combat là doit
mobiliser en effet toutes les forces
toutes les sensibilités toute
l'intelligence nécessaire en quelques
secondes justement là-dessus dans les
engagements d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017
quand vous discutez avec lui d'une
alliance il vous garantit la mise en
place de la proportionnelle au
législative toujours rien 5 ans et demi
après est-ce que c'est un engagement non
tenu où ça le sera avant la fin du
décennat
dernière question François Bayrou vous
êtes maire de Pau depuis 2014 vous en
avez encore pour 28 ans si vous voulez
battre le record d'André la Barère
quel sens vous donner
je ne pense pas que je battrai celui-là
dans cette ville que vous n'avez jamais
quitté depuis votre naissance et Luc
local sans discontinué à partir de 1982
vous vivez à Bordères dans le village où
vous êtes né je le disais en
introduction c'est à 16 km de peau quel
sens vous donner à votre mandat de maire
que celui-ci dure 35 ans avant de la
Barère ou non quel est l'enjeu pour une
ville comme Pau et
on précise quand même que les moyens les
urgences sont pas les mêmes qu'à
l'époque la Barrère
c'est une de mes grandes fierté comme
vous le sentez bien c'est pas seulement
d'exercer un mandat d'être choisi par
ses concitoyens mais de pouvoir changer
le visage d'une ville
ces temps-ci il ne se passe pas de
journée sans que des concitoyens
viennent me voir en disant on n'est pas
toujours d'accord avec vous
politiquement mais ce que vous avez fait
pour la ville c'est formidable et je
vous invite à venir visiter parce que je
crois que c'est authentiquement
sensible on peut on peut voir ce qui
s'est passé dans le visage de cette
ville
dans ces équipements dans
l'organisation de la cité y compris
l'organisation morale parce qu'on a
lancé par exemple un plan tissolitude
dans pour moi l'urgence devrait être
constaté par tout
on a fait sur le plan de la cité de
l'urbanisme des grands équipements
sportifs culturels
on a fait des choses qui je crois sont
tellement fortes que
[Musique]
le grand réseau qui s'appelle LinkedIn
que vous connaissez tous parce que tous
les professionnels sont adhérents au
réseau
25 millions d'adhérents en France 850
millions dans le monde
LinkedIn vient de lancer une grande
enquête parmi ces adhérents pour savoir
la ville où il souhaiterait s'installer
et ses peaux qui arrivent en tête
sur les deux études successives pour
arriver en tête devant Bordeaux devant
Toulouse devant Nice devant Marseille
et c'est pour moi comme une récompense
de voir à quel point une ville dont
vous-même avez insinué c'est que pendant
très longtemps on a eu le sentiment
qu'elle était en déclin et tout d'un
coup on découvre que elle peut rayonner
à nouveau et attirer et donc pour moi
c'est une oui c'est une grande fierté et
ça veut dire une deuxième chose
la plupart de nos concitoyens pensent
que la politique ne peut pas faire
grand-chose
tout ça qui pense que c'est des mots que
c'est sympathique parfois antipathique
souvent mais que ça ne peut pas faire
grand-chose or on peut attester quand on
réussit à changer le visage d'une ville
quand peu de temps parce qu'on a fait ça
en quelques années seulement quand peu
de temps le visage d'une ville peut
changer alors Baudelaire a dit une fois
pour toutes que la forme d'une ville
change plus vite et là que le cœur d'un
mortel il a dit ça après les travaux de
Haussmann à Paris
mon ambition c'est qu'on puisse un peu
aussi changer le cœur de ceux qui
habitent dans dans une ville alors je
n'assume nuit pas le déclin de Pau je
vous demandais juste comment passer
derrière 35 ans du mandat d'un même
homme avec des moyens qui ne sont pas
les mêmes parce que l'argent se fait
plus rare me semble-t-il si je suis on a
pu remobiliser voilà c'est ça quel
visage vous souhaitez donner que votre
mandat dure 2 3 4 fois alors André la
Barrère que vous citez avec qui j'ai eu
de nombreux débats et qui avait un
caractère flamboyant
André la Barrère disait tout sera la
Florence du 21e siècle et vous vous en
tenez à ça c'était déjà gonflé et moi je
me contente pas de le dire je fais tout
ce que je peux pour que ça soit vrai ce
qui est encore plus gonflé probablement
que ce qu'aurait la Barrère exprimait
merci François Bayrou d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à venir partager sur
France Culture ce qui fait depuis plus
d'un demi-siècle votre sens politique
j'ai commencé l'émission avec la
taquinerie d'un parallèle Henri IV
François bayrouge la terminerai donc en
rappelant la parution il y a presque 30
ans d'une biographie d'Henri IV que vous
avez signé François Bayrou Henri IV le
roi est libre ce qui est pas mal sorti
chez Flammarion et donc toujours
disponible voilà pour la trace écrite si
la trace orale vous intéresse l'émission
d'aujourd'hui ainsi que la collection
complète sont à retrouver sur le site
France culture.fr